still not sure what to ask Santa for
well lucky for you this December is
busier than normal so we've got some
great ideas for your wish list here are
10 of the biggest games coming out in
December 2022.
the callista protocol is a new survival
horror game set on one of Jupiter's
moons Callisto more specifically it's
set in a prison called Black Iron
located on Callisto in 2320 with
protagonist Jacob Lee finding himself
trapped as mutated humans begin taking
over and murdering other inmates if dead
things in space sound familiar that's
because the kalista protocol is being
developed by Dead Space co-creator Glenn
schofield's new company Striking
Distance Studios the game features a mix
of up close melee combat and ranged
Weaponry letting you improvise and
decide what the best tool in a specific
situation is because of relatively
limited ammunition like in most survival
horror games you won't be blasting away
mindlessly trying to survive however
powerful weapons will still be able to
destroy limbs potentially slowing down
enemies as they approach I'm way too
scared to play the kalista protocol but
you can play it for me when the game
releases for PC and every console except
for switch on December 2nd
Marvel's midnight Suns is the next game
from developer for axis games the studio
behind civilization and the past three
x-com games though it has tactical
strategy elements Marvel's midnight Suns
is far from a superhero reskin of XCOM
instead of set abilities Your Heroes
will each have a deck of ability cards
that get shuffled together when you
bring three of them into combat together
these cards range from basic attacks to
special skills allowing you to buff
other players or toss enemies around the
battlefield the cards can also be
customized with variations to suit your
playstyle the story in Midnight Suns is
based Loosely on the 90s comic book
series rise of the midnight Suns a
crossover event that paired up the
Avengers with more Supernatural and
Magic based characters to stop a demonic
threat Marvel's midnight Suns will drop
for PlayStation 5 Xbox series xns and PC
on December 2nd
Need for Speed has a number of games
about street racing but Need for Speed
Unbound just might be one of the most
distinct entries in the long-running
series thanks to its cel-shaded visuals
that make it look like a high-speed
anime series in the story players will
attempt to win the grand the ultimate
street racing challenge in Lakeshore
collecting cars and using them as a
canvas to show off their personal style
on the streets EA has confirmed that
they'll be 143 cards to collect and
customize with the list of available
Vehicles being a mix of iconic racing
machines and modern Monsters the game
has more than 10 000 customization
options to choose from that includes
more than just installing new parts and
whether you're just adding new
graffiti-like effects or taking first
place you're gonna want something dope
to listen to Unbound will have more than
70 tracks with the playlist including
ASAP Rocky Kelvin crash slow tie and
more in a collection inspired by global
hip-hop artists Need for Speed Unbound
will be racing onto PlayStation 5 Xbox
series X and S and PC on December 2nd
hello neighbor 2 is a stealth Adventure
game that also falls into the family
friendly horror genre it's the sequel to
2017's hello neighbor but it's the third
game in the series if you count the 2019
multiplayer game secret neighbor unlike
the first game which had you
investigating your neighbor's basement
for Secrets the entire town of
ravenbrooks is hiding secrets from you
this time around as Quentin your job is
to sneak around town and get to the
bottom of the series of missing persons
reports coming from this suspiciously
peaceful town but don't expect to find
those Secrets easily hello neighbor 2
features sophisticated AI controlled
neighbors that will learn from you and
do everything they can to keep you away
from the skeletons in their closet hello
neighbor 2 is sneaking onto PC and every
console except for switch on December
6th it'll also be available Day One on
Game Pass
chained Echoes is a 16-bit style jrpg
set in the fantasy world of Atlantis a
vast continent with Three Kingdoms At
War in the game you play as a group of
Heroes that aim to bring an end to that
war to do this you'll travel across
various locations battling enemies using
a sword magic or even a mech suit
chained Echoes features fast-paced
turn-based combat tons of items to loot
a complex skill system a customizable
Airship and music inspired by classic
PlayStation RPGs of the past find out if
you can bring peace to this nation when
chained Echoes Launches on PC in every
console on December 8th
choo choo Charles is an open world
Adventure horror game in which your goal
is to destroy a bloodthirsty spider
train named Charles let me say that
again so it really sinks in a
bloodthirsty spider train named Charles
reminds me of how Thomas the Tank Engine
has made an appearance as the enemy in a
number of games thanks to mods in the
game you'll navigate your own train
through a Tetris Play area to loot carry
out missions and help settlers in order
to upgrade your train and obtain
high-powered weapons and when you're
ready you can take on Charles and
finally put an end to his Terror you can
develop a fear of trains when choo choo
Charles comes to PC on December 9th
in Dragon Quest Treasures you play as
Eric and his sister Mia after being
transported to the land of free roaming
monsters called draconia luckily not all
of these monsters are out to get you and
some can be befriended in order to
better Traverse the map and score
Treasures from hard to reach places it's
up to you to put together the best
treasure hunting game possible and to
help you do that there's a base where
you can swap party members or send
groups out on their own for a chance at
scoring rare loot draconia is also home
to the seven Dragon stones and you'll
have to beat rival gangs to each one if
you're keen on having the whole
collection what will you find when
Dragon Quest Treasures releases on
switch December 9th
Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII reunion is
a faithful retelling of the 2007 PSP
title Crisis Core Final Fantasy VII at
the center of the game is Zach Fair a
young Shinra soldier who both original
Final Fantasy fans and Final Fantasy VII
remake fans alike will recognize as a
close colleague of Cloud Strife the game
follows his mission to locate a missing
Soldier by the name of Genesis Rhapsody
though as you can imagine things don't
go quite as smoothly as Zach might have
hoped the game acts as a prequel to
Final Fantasy VII with Zack's story
being a significant chapter in the lives
of cloud Tifa aerith and sephiroth
players can look forward to improved HD
graphics refreshed character models
fully voice acted dialogue and a new
arrangement for the soundtrack it will
also serve as our first HD look at some
key locations that will surely be in the
next chapters of the Final Fantasy
remake Trilogy you can relive your PSP
days when Crisis Core Final Fantasy 7
reunion drops on PC in every console on
December 13th
high on life is a first person shooter
from the mind of Rick and Morty and
solar opposites co-creator Justin
Roiland and squanch games in the main
campaign you play as an unemployed high
school graduate who teams up with a
group of talking guns to save the cosmos
from an alien cartel looking to
literally get high off Humanity to do
this you'll travel to a variety of
locations such as a jungle paradise and
a City built inside of an asteroid
you'll meet interesting weird and
hilarious characters collect Loot and an
array of alien technology and kick a ton
of Intergalactic ass my own life is
coming to PC Xbox One and Xbox series
xns on December 13th and will be
playable on Xbox game pass at launch we
also have 30 minutes of gameplay up on
the channel right now so check it out
The Witcher 3 wild Hunt is one of my
favorite games of all time in this
December the game is getting a facelift
for next-gen consoles and PC The Witcher
3 will now include Ray tracing and
ambient occlusion on PC PlayStation 5
and Xbox series X a photo mode and new
camera modes that bring it closer to
Garrow there are a variety of other
quality of life improvements coming with
the update including new walking and
jogging options for Geral and the
ability to change the size of the game's
subtitles the new update arrives on
December 14th alongside the complete
edition which includes the base game all
DLC and the two major expansions hearts
of stone and blood and wine at launch
the complete edition will be digital
only but the physical version is coming
later for those who already own The
Witcher 3 wild Hunt on PlayStation 4
Xbox One and PC they can get the next
gen upgrades for free let us know in the
comments which game you're most excited
to play in December and look out for the
biggest games of January video later in
the month
foreign